all right little uh fill in the blank
time
coaching carousel edition you've got
plenty of names out there that have
emerged for the jobs that are still
vacant and right now there are only
three the panthers the browns and the
giants washington officially filled
their vacancy on
wednesday with the announcement that ron
rivera has been hired we assume there's
going to be a vacancy in dallas but who
the hell knows why yeah i mean that's
the that's the wild card here you know
i'm i i want to include dallas here with
some of these questions we're going to
have here in a little bit
well i think let's assume the job is
going to be open because chris if they
were going to keep jason garrett
i think that by now right he would have
leaked to somebody yes just to get us
all
yeah familiar with and accustomed to the
idea that he may be back right you have
to you have to do that you can't drop
that out of nowhere oh by the way he's
staying yes you have to let people know
there's a chance he may stay so let's
assume the cowboys will eventually be in
play yeah okay let's play fill in the
blank then as it relates to the coaching
carousel and let's start with eric b
enemy the offensive coordinator of the
kansas city chiefs who was overlooked
last year and maybe he shouldn't have
been this year he is a candidate for
these jobs he's definitely in the mixing
carolina he's one of the three guys
they're looking at most carefully if i
was eric b enemy i would take the blank
job yes well okay and we're just saying
like it's he's getting offered by
everybody right and he's gonna make it
let's assume that everybody offers him
the job and he's he's got his choice yes
even though that's probably not going to
happen let's assume he's got his choice
of all open jobs if he had his choice i
would tell eric brienne to go to the
cleveland browns i think that's the like
first off you're an offensive coach so
what do you want to do when you take
over as the head coach slash officer
coordinator it looks kind of good when
your offense does well when you're the
offensive coordinator head coach it's
good for just the perceived notion that
it was the right hire and getting
everybody in the fan base behind you so
i look at the cleveland browns as being
that team out there right now to go
oh that has a similar skill set to what
he had in kansas city to where he can
make that offense i think transition
very easily i mean you know the running
back position of course kareem hunt's
there already he's gonna know the
offense but to have him and nick chubb
along with those receivers and baker
mayfield and a young tight end i feel
like he can just mold it right into like
kansas city 2.0 that would be the one
that makes sense to me
yeah but my concern with cleveland is
very simple and fundamental i know
i don't think ownership knows what
they're doing and i say that with as
much respect and deference as i possibly
can but we now have seven years of
evidence that we can look at yeah and
we've seen the reports there's so much
of a sense that jimmy haslam just
listens to too many different people and
doesn't have his own clear firm vision
and doesn't have the patience the irony
is this guy was a minority owner of the
pittsburgh steelers the team that is the
gold standard when it comes to patience
with a coaching staff patience with a
front office and it is just a revolving
door that constantly spins i wouldn't
want to step into that unless i was damn
sure that things have changed they tried
to change it with hugh jackson and they
as a result kept him much longer than
they should have so i'd have trepidation
about the cleveland browns i think if
i'm eric the enemy i'm seriously
considering the carolina panthers now
yeah newton's my guy maybe he isn't but
i feel like david tepper is going to be
as former steelers minority owners go
far more likely to operate like the
steelers do
than uh than the haslems and and i so i
think if i if i take that job i'm going
to be there i'm going to get a fair
opportunity to turn things around
and and i'm with an organization that is
run by one of the owners that gets it
you know look they're all making a ton
of money but some of them get it and
some of them don't and i'm willing to
put david tepper for now into the heat
gets it category so i'd be more inclined
to take that job yeah i hear you and
there's like we just talked about with
cleveland there's some offensive
firepower there in carolina that's young
and can be molded and then you know of
course that's cam newton so i get it
and yeah christian mccaffrey i mean the
guy who's a candidate for offensive
player of the year e.j the third 1000
and 1000 yard rushing receiving guy in
league history but you're right there's
plenty there to work with even if you do
move on at quarterback all right blank
is the perfect spot for ravens offensive
coordinator greg roman well i you know
of course my my first my first answer
there just as far as what greg roman
wants to coach and how he wants to coach
is carolina you know just as far as how
it would molds together with his style
offense you know yes a cam newton would
fit everything he wants to do is he
going to be able to run cam newton as
much as he's run lamar jackson no but
he'll be able to scare everybody and
have the threat of that with cam newton
let alone like you talked about the
christian mccaffrey factor dj moore fake
speed sweep curtis samuel fake speed
sweep so you know they have an offensive
line that's kind of big and hulking
already i think that can really fit the
way his scheme is coached and things
like that so i look at the panthers as
being you know right there is maybe a
little advantage to the cowboys because
the cowboys would be close too as far as
he could pull that off
yeah i just would worry about what i'm
getting myself into in dallas although
it is one of the marquee organizations
in all of sport you don't get to be
the traditional typical head coach there
because the joneses are so involved in
everything that happens and i think they
can easily undermine what you're trying
to do as the coach of the organization
i'm going to say the ravens are the best
spot for greg roman okay i think he
should wait a year i really do all right
i didn't know that was on the table i
like that answer that's probably what i
would say too but go ahead yes be
because i
we just kind of woke up to
the possibility of roman being a a
shortlist a-list head coaching candidate
in the past couple of months
i think for him
he should spend a whole year basking in
that attention that glow a full season
of of a presumption that he's going to
be the top guy right the lincoln rally
dynamic where you know you just you gets
it gets baked into everyone's mindset
that this is the guy we need to go
higher and then the next cycle you see
what's out there because ultimately i
think what you want to have is a
quarterback like a lamar jackson like a
colin kaepernick who greg roman had done
such great work with in the past you
need to you know he put together a great
offense for lamar jackson that doesn't
mean he's going to put together a great
offense for some other quarterback that
doesn't have the same skill set that's
the big question
you want to be confident that you're
going to have the opportunity to match
up what you're good at doing
with players who are good at doing the
things that you're good at putting
together i think that's exactly right
and i hear you too i think it you know
it could be a little early
you bask in that glory like you said you
expand your offense you show that it's
more than just running next year because
you would figure some teams you're gonna
catch on to the running game and lamar
jackson and all that too and he'll have
to expand and go to the next phase which
i think will only ultimately make him a
better head coach slash offensive
coordinator when he does get that job
but there is risk in doing that yes
right because you're hot now that that
window does not stay open no definitely
you can you can't risk it because of
that right there you just can't you just
if you get offered and you like the job
you got to take it and run with it and
hope for the best
and here's the other thing too i mean
right now we have a limited selection of
teams browns giants panthers probably
the cowboys we're only four days removed
from the end of the regular season and
we have seen in the past that kind of
delayed reaction firing whether it's a
guy who's coaching a playoff team that
loses in the wild card round that loses
in the divisional round remember marty
schottenheimer was fired by the chargers
ridiculously late 13 14 years ago after
a 14-2 season so
there may be something else that pops up
hell the colts job came open when we
thought josh mcdaniels was taking it and
it fell together perfectly for frank
reich so you never know what else is
going to pop up but based on what we
have now it is a limited selection and i
don't know that any of those would jump
out to me as places i must go to if i'm
greg roman all right next one the blank
are going to hire mike mccarthy this
year well i i mean you know of course i
don't know this right jim all right to
me the mo the one that makes the most
sense where mike mccarthy i think would
fit best all right
is the dallas cowboys i really do i
think he's perfect you know he's like in
an army general just tell okay what you
just say jones family don't worry i'll
make the team tougher we'll be better in
situational football you know i'll add a
little splash of toughness to both sides
of the ball who knows who he brings in
as a defensive coordinator you know
traditionally he's kind of believed in
pretty creative guys in that side of the
ball with dom capers who was
definitely a game plan specific type guy
but i just look at mccarthy as being the
right guy in dallas right now out of the
options that are there and if you're
going to make me choose from mccarthy
because dallas is ready to win right now
and mike mccarthy can win right now we
know he's capable of bringing the team
to the nfc championship team nfc
championship the super bowl and one
thing we do know is he'll coach them
tough you know there was never that
issue in green bay they were always
tough and buttoned up and had an
approach you know my complaint was
always just creativity on the offensive
side of the ball and he seems very aware
of that just in the interviews i saw
when he was doing that media tour
that's a hell of a graphic we had up
there i didn't know we had a member of
the mccarthy family working in the
control room i mean yeah you have to
give him some credit but he's had brett
favre and aaron rodgers yeah i get it i
know chris i know in the two and a half
years that we've been doing this show
together right there are two coaches
that you have complained about the most
loudly when it comes to lack of
offensive creativity yes one is the
current coach of the cowboys and the
other is the guy you're trying to put
into the job well yeah you're right uh i
uh is scary it's the scariest thing
about it be the number one thing
interviewing mike mccarthy is
you know what are you gonna do a little
differently about your offense than you
did in green bay yeah it frustrated me i
mean he you know had the greatest
quarterback i've ever seen in my life
doing some of the most basic bull crap i
ever saw two at times so yeah that did
bother me it wasn't always like that it
wasn't like that early on in his career
i don't know where he lost his way there
or whatever happened but uh i just think
there's a lot of things that match up
what's your answer i mean what would you
say
i'd say of the jobs that are currently
open the cleveland browns and i think
that would be the kind of move the
browns would make that would cause me to
believe they're finally starting to
figure out how to properly run that team
because
if if mccarthy does
in cleveland what he did in green bay my
god it transforms the franchise right
now can he do it with baker mayfield i
have real questions about baker mayfield
when you look at his performance in 2019
it was bottom of the barrel in relation
to other starting quarterbacks in the
nfl 22 touchdowns 21 interceptions and i
don't you know i don't know which is the
real baker mayfield 2018 or 2019 i don't
know what mike mccarthy thinks of baker
mayfield but
um if
if he does with him what he did with
farvin rogers uh that would be the kind
of thing that finally turns the browns
into something they haven't been over
the past 20 years and that is
a contending team so um i think that
mccarthy would make sense there and and
i i just i think that the way things
ended the last couple of years he was in
green bay the fact that the packers are
13-3 the first year without him that
bleacher report article from tyler dunn
yeah that exposed a lot of dysfunction
i'd want to do my due diligence on all
those things before offering mike
mccarthy the job but i think cleveland
makes sense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports